hundred days to make their case get a
mandate and perhaps change a nation's
fate for the major parties fighting off
newcomers as much as each other the Sky
News poll of polls shows labor just the
head of the Conservatives but the poll
of Scottish polls show an entrenched
surge in support for the SNP based on
those figures a projected hung
parliament with labour the largest party
short of an overall majority by 44 seats
the SNP could win 53 seats meaning SNP
labour the only possible to party
majority coalition even with these
projections you can't predict who will
actually be walking through that door in
May but you can say surely privately ed
Miliband will be considering his options
with the SNP and that provides an
opening for the Conservatives to
threaten England with the notion of a
tart and backed coalition and economic
chaos the Prime Minister invited Sky
News into the Cabinet Room today his
message as the eurozone crisis
resurfaces don't risk labor we've had
the recovery for over a year now and it
still hasn't transferred into the polls
for yourself you must be worried that
that what why normal obviously I'm
worried about the future of our country
if we end up with a unstable left-wing
government that starts to borrow and
spend and wreck the economic progress
that we've made of course I worry about
that but we have a hundred days to go to
make this argument today new figures
showed the recovery Sloane to northpoint
five percent growth in the last quarter
it's still solid over the year the
Vauxhall van factory in Luton a potent
symbol for the economy an extra shift
added yesterday new jobs built on pay
cuts and freezes so recovery and cost of
living crisis in one production line hey
well five years ago we didn't know we're
going to have a job you know and
everyone was quite worried and now
everyone's a rich soy
ed miliband campaigning today not on the
economy but saving the NHS with a
ten-year plan our country's most
precious institution faces i believe is
most perilous moment in a generation and
it is a choice of two futures carrying
on with a conservative plan which has
already led to an NHS in crisis and
threatens the service as we know it or a
Labour plan to rescue Aeryn a chair or
near point in the lib dems stronghold of
Berman's II Nick Clegg out campaigning
we need to fight and fight very hard in
every street on every doorstep to get
our message across that we want to build
a both a stronger economy and a fairer
society and I think we were the only
party that now offers that balance and
this is your folks still talking like 30
40 oh no no no many many many many more
may be many we got 56 MP and for infant
for started so with all the major
parties facing a squeeze even the Deputy
PM mucking in it's all hands on deck
puzzle Islam Sky News